I've often bragged that I am immune to
poison ivy because I got a really bad
case of it years ago and then I became
immune that's what I said and and so
yesterday I was I was walking through
the woods and I traipse right through a
whole patch of poison ivy because I'm
immune to it right and anyway fast
forwarding to the end of the story I'm
not immune as it turns out I have I have
since discovered over the last day I
don't know I got it into my head that
that's it is that even a thing becoming
immune to poison ivy
somehow I got that into my head and I
would tell people that and nobody ever
corrected me why didn't anyone ever tell
me like no that's not a thing you're
definitely not no one ever did so was
that was everyone just playing along
waiting for this moment and if that's
the case then then well played well
played everybody but at the very least I
will say that I have suffered this
poison ivy rash with quiet quiet dignity
in my house I've only complained about
it incessantly to everybody in this
house and now to the whole world other
than that I haven't complained about it
at all I've just been I've been very
stoic and so I think in that way I'm an
example to everybody okay we begin with
just a an unbelievable story or maybe
it's unfortunately very believable I
don't know
I'm reported yesterday in the Daily wire
the report says a professor presented a
lesson to students at the University of
North Texas titled sexual pleasure and
response in infants big-league politics
first reported last week moreover as
highlighted by the college fix on Friday
the textbook for the same course
psychology and sexual behavior suggests
that students take take field trips to
preschools and elementary schools to
observe students sexual interactions as
this this is real this is an actual
course at an actual university in
America the lesson plan on sexuality and
infants which can be which there's a
link to it if you go look at this
article you can see the LES plant it's
from the 13th edition
of our sexuality that's the course the
course is listed textbook that's what
our sexuality is one section of the
document according to the fix titled
teaching ideas suggests that instructors
take students on a field trip to observe
children possibly engaging in sexual
interactions during recess hours the
textbook says take the class to a local
elementary school playground or ask
permission for a few of your students to
attend various school playgrounds
preschools or daycare centers during
recess to observe behaviors of children
ask students to note interactions
between same-sex and mixed sex groups
rich which group was more frequent which
behaviors were most frequent what kind
of touching did children engage him what
about teasing behaviors were there any
overtly sexual interactions what was the
age range of children being observed
have students write a report comparing
their observations with information in
the text it's unclear if the parents of
the young students potentially so it's
we don't know if when it says ask
permission who is who are we asking
permission the parents or the teacher of
course doesn't doesn't whatever the case
it doesn't make it any better one of the
textbooks editors Carla Bower was
interviewed by the college fix and she
said that she's you know one of the
people responsible for this although she
claims that the the other editor of the
textbook who's now deceased wrote the
guide where the field trips were
suggested and so she tried to distance
herself from as I she didn't know
anything about that and if you're
wondering what the course objectives are
the course objectives read as follows
number one to describe human sexuality
from historical and multicultural
perspectives to define to define major
theoretical perspectives that influence
the scientific study of human sexuality
to explain the significant research
methodologies within disap
to examine the socially constructed
nature of sexual identities to describe
how sexuality overlaps with various
social institutions to recognize the
changing nature of social norms okay so
a couple of things here first of all
you've noticed that there really seems
to be a movement afoot to normalize
pedophilia yet we're always told that no
such movement exists you know pay no
attention to the man behind the curtain
our eyes are fooling us and we see stuff
like this and and and we say well it
looks like this is a normalization of
pedophilia and yet we're always a no
though no that's not happening that's
not happening well I think this makes it
pretty clear doesn't it
and it's it's not although I started by
calling this unbelievable I don't mean
that in a literal sense because it is
very believable unfortunately because
this is what happens when you begin to
break down sexual boundaries the G K
Chesterton talks about as I've mentioned
this quote for him before because it's
so relevant to what we see going on in
our culture especially as it pertains to
sexuality and what he says is you know
you're walking down the street and you
come across a fence you're not going to
just tear down the fence without knowing
why the fence is there and what it is
meant to can do to contain right you're
not you're not gonna just just just
announce oh we need to take down this
fence first you want to know why is that
fence there what purpose does it serve
is it holding back some sort of rabid
dog or something like that mean there
could be a lot of good reasons for a
fence now the point is what we've done
in our culture with sexual boundaries is
we've just started tearing down fences
without ever stopping to consider why
those fences were there and what sorts
of rabid dogs
they were trying to contain and the
other problem is once you begin this
project of tearing down sexual
boundaries it becomes really hard to
erect them somewhere else once you've
said now we're gonna tear down this
boundary and that one right this is all
about social norms where we're getting
rid of all the social norms well there's
some things our social norms for a
reason and when when a when a phrase
like social norm becomes a dirty word
like it's a bad thing it's a bad thing
to uphold social now we need we need to
tear down social norms just because
their norms well it was a social norm in
our society that pedophilia is wrong now
you don't sexualize children that was a
social norm that's a good social norm
it's a norm for a reason but once you
start tearing down those fences and it
becomes difficult to go somewhere else
and rebuild a fence and that's what's
happening here and as part of this so
you have the tearing down of boundaries
what you also have is to be just reading
through the course objectives that I did
I just read through sex sexuality sex
sex sex there's this obsession with sex
and sexuality and in in in seeing
everyone all people as these inherently
sexual beings including children and
that's another thing that you fight on
the left is this obsessing is seen in
sexual terms as much as they claim that
oh my my sex life is none of your
business
sex is a private thing as much as they
claim that the they actually believe the
exact the exact opposite now I believe
that that your sex slave is none of my
business is as long as you're not
abusing or raping and releasing anyone
but other
than that it is I don't want to know
don't don't talk to me about it
you don't don't advertise it you don't
need to go marching down the street
telling everybody we don't need to know
now that's how I feel about it the left
they they claim that they say that's
none of your business but then they go
out in the street and they march and
they and they announce and they tell
everybody they advertise their sexuality
and this is where it ends up the second
thing to note here is although I believe
this is part of a movement in our
society to normalize pedophilia we also
have to understand that this is not new
this is the kind of research that Alfred
Kinsey used to do in the early part of
the 20th century and Kinsey is
considered a pioneer a hero even to the
left Alfred Kinsey is he's the Godfather
of modern sex education and in sex
education modern sex education is based
on his work but he was a pervert and a
deviant who studied the sexual responses
of molested children very similar to
what you just read here he would have
Alfred Kinsey would have pedophiles
raped children and record their
experiences in like a journal and then
they would come in and they would have
meetings with Kinsey where they would
talk about their experiences raping
children and how the children responded
to it and Kinsey would study the these
these interactions he never reported it
to police didn't tell police about it a
pedophile would come to him and say you
know I raped children and Kinsey would
say okay great here's a notebook next
time you do it make sure you take notes
now I'm not making that up
that's this was what L Alfred Kinsey
would do that's the kind of work if we
can call it that that this psychopath
did and yet our public school sex
education courses are based around his
work and this thing that I just
from this University and in Texas that's
exactly the kind of thing that he would
do and now we're seeing that come to the
forefront again more explicitly just
completely horrific alright um speaking
of horrific there's a story out of out
of Australia a man 36 year old man was
arrested put in jail charged with sexual
assault after he stopped to help a woman
whose car was broken down and and 'min
held her and then he was later accused
of stalking her and assaulting her the
problem is that he did no such thing he
did stop to help her he worked on her
car for two hours apparently trying to
help this woman who was stranded but he
did not assault her and evidence
including security cameras revealed and
confirmed that he was innocent so this
guy performed this good deed going out
of his way for a fellow human being and
she turned around and accused him of
rape he was put he spent some time in
jail before he was finally cleared of
charges he lost his relationship his his
name was was was run through the mud all
because he did this good thing for
another person there was there's a quote
from him I'll see if I can find a quote
from him that is just so sad but also
kind of profound and it sort of sums up
where we are he was interviewed about
his experiences after finally being
after finally being vindicated and he
said I always helped people all my life
and this was the first time a snake bit
me he said he'll he'll probably never
help again I don't want that to happen
again
I'll probably never help again is what
he said this is a guy who was a good
Samaritan used to helping out his fellow
human beings and now he's saying well
never gonna do that again I don't blame
him I mean I certainly couldn't possibly
blame him for that but
I think you've that's that's what we're
finding now is you have a lot of
otherwise chivalrous and good men who
don't who are afraid of you know going
out of their way putting themselves out
there to help another person especially
a woman because they don't want to be
accused of anything they don't to be
accused of being a sexist they don't
want to be accused of it and and worst
case scenario they don't wanna be
accused with with a situation like this
and that's yet another problem with as I
pointed out many times with something
like the me to movement with the hiss
you know hysteria that we found in the
me to movement is that it engenders
suspicion between the sexes on both
sides where women begin to believe that
you know every man is is a potential
rapist out to assault her and men begin
to believe that any woman could
potentially falsely accuse him of
something and so you have this suspicion
and both groups kind of avoiding each
other and try not to be around each
other and that's not a healthy situation
for society so that's that's pretty
terrible all right so I wrote something
yesterday that I wanted to I wanted to
go through here as we talked about on
the show yesterday after that law in
Georgia was passed which makes abortion
basically illegal after six weeks with
exceptions the left obviously reacted as
you expect them to react and there was a
woman on CNN we played the clip of this
woman Christine Quinn I believe was
raped who who was so overcome with anger
that she and she became delusional she
started screaming about how unborn
babies are not human beings they're part
of the woman's body now I talk about why
that's obviously a ridiculous and stupid
argument clearly the unborn child is a
human being but that is one of the
really stupid arguments that pro aborts
put forward it's only one though there's
a whole list of really bad
dumb pro-abortion arguments I wrote
something yesterday going through what I
consider to be sort of the top 7 dumbest
pro-abortion arguments I thought I would
I would do that here on the show as well
go through them since the top 7 dumbest
pro-abortion arguments aside from the
one about not being a human being we
already covered that that's probably
kind of the mack daddy of dumb arguments
that probably would be number one but
putting that to the side we'll go
through the list 7 to 1 so starting at
number 7 dumb argument you can't be
against abortion unless you're willing
to adopt unwanted babies we've talked
about this before oh that's that's the
argument and of course a great many pro
lifers do indeed adopt unwanted babies
but none of us can adopt all of them and
some of us can't adopt any of them the
fact that we are limited in our
resources does not prove that we're
hypocrites and even if it did prove that
that in itself would not prove that our
position is flawed even if you could
prove that we are immigrants and we you
know with it's we should be out adopting
babies and we're not that doesn't mean
anything about what we're claiming about
the nature of abortion but in any case
it doesn't make any sense because if we
can only oppose the murder of those who
we are able and willing to personally
care for and subsidize that would mean
that we cannot oppose the murder of
almost anyone on earth because we can't
care for and subsidize the vast vast
majority of people who currently live
there are 7 billion people on earth you
cannot care for all 7 billion so if this
is the standard and you know you are I
can only feed and clothe the vanishingly
small percentage of people on earth and
that would mean that we can only really
care about the fate and oppose the
murder of that very small percentage and
that would mean that we have to remain
silent about things like genocide and
school shootings because hey we you know
we're not stepping up to care for those
people but that of course doesn't make
any sense whatsoever so that's a bad
argument
number six no uterus no opinion now
leftist of course can't really make this
argument anymore because they also say
that you know your possession of a
uterus has nothing at all to do with
your gender and means nothing anyway so
they've already made that they have
neutralized that argument themselves
they've ruled that argument out which is
probably for the best because it's a
dumb argument anyway abortion is a moral
and legal issue so we use our brains to
sort through it not our reproductive
organs so what that what the what the
motto really should be is no brain no
opinion now that's true you don't have a
brain then you shouldn't be voicing your
opinion on this issue or any other but
I'm afraid that that might rule out a
large portion of the pro-abortion side
so that's the problem there number 5 you
you can't force a woman to reproduce now
I agree with that statement it's it
would be it would be horrific to force
women to reproduce unfortunately that
has nothing to do with abortion though
because a woman does not reproduce when
she gives birth in the hospital
reproduction occurs at conception so the
when a baby is born that is not an act
of reproduction reproduction has already
happened it is the product of that
reproduction the thing that has been
reproduced that is what's being born so
the question isn't should women be
required to reproduce obviously they
should the question is should a woman be
allowed to purposely kill that which has
already been produced and the answer to
that is no number four pro-lifers want
to control women's bodies right we hear
this all the time
well of course the body that's directly
in dispute is not the woman's it's it's
the child's it's true that the woman
uses her body to sustain the child's
body but that's just as much the case
after birth as it is before I use my
body to care for my born children I use
my body to do that I use my body to to
clothe them provide for them feed them I
mean whatever I do for my kids or for
anyone else I'm using my body to do it
because
I in my body I can't do it any other way
I can't just sit back and with the power
of my brain make things move around and
I'm not professor X in x-men so I have
to do that everything I do for my kids I
use my body to do it what's more the law
requires me to do those things for my
kids to care for them provide for them
which means which means the law requires
me to use my body to do those things I'm
not allowed to claim bodily autonomy and
then just cease all parental activities
if I did that my body and myself all
together we would all go to jail if I
did that now does that mean that the
laws against neglect and endangerment
control my body you know it may be in a
very weird and indirect sense but the
point of the laws certainly is not to
control my body the point of the law is
to protect children and so the point of
making abortion illegal is not to
control women's bodies but to protect
children that's that's the point number
three this is a classic pro pro-lifers
are only pro birth right they don't care
about babies after they're born once
again this is irrelevant even if it's
true but it isn't true our whole point
is that there's no difference between a
baby inside the womb and a baby outside
of the womb we cherish them both so if
we didn't care about babies outside the
womb then and we wouldn't be constantly
insisting that a child inside the womb
is just like a child outside the womb
now follow the logic here what we're
saying is a child inside the womb is
like a child outside the womb therefore
the child inside the womb should be
treated with value and dignity this line
of reasoning clearly indicates that we
think that children outside of the womb
have value and dignity our our whole
case is is that sort of the linchpin of
our entire case also of course pro
lifers are exceedingly charitable they
we give to people in need all the time
and if you're going to make this claim
about pro lifers don't care about kids
after birth
you have to come forward with some sort
of data some information to prove that
improve for instance that pro-lifers you
know don't give the charity and don't
help the less fortunate again even if
you could prove that that would not
prove anything about abortion but you
can't even prove that so this is a an
argument that is not only irrelevant and
stupid but fabricated out of thin air
number two the pro-life movement is just
a bunch of men bossing women around you
know pro-lifers are a bunch of and this
clearly is is once again irrelevant
because either the pro-life position is
wrong or it's right and if it's right it
would still be right even if men were
the only ones arguing for it
but men are not the only ones far from
it the pro-life movement is run
predominantly by women it's mostly women
working at pregnancy centers it's mostly
women at the March for Life it's mostly
women praying outside of abortion
clinics and so it'sit's the idea that
the pro-life movement is some sort of
male-dominated thing is a once again
completely baseless number one and this
is maybe this is the biggest one of all
even more than unborn babies aren't
aren't human women have the right to
choose the right to choose yeah we hear
that phrase so often that we take it for
granted but it actually is a is a is a
concept without meaning without content
it doesn't mean anything do women have
the right to choose no of course they
don't it's your your right to make a
choice depends entirely on the nature of
the choice now physically you can choose
to do whatever you want within the laws
of physics but legally there are
hundreds upon hundreds of things you
cannot choose to do you can't choose
arson or rape or theft or or tax evasion
or burglary or vandal
you can't choose murder either unless
your victim happens to be still inside
the womb but when someone insists that
women have the right to choose you know
that statement the right to choose is a
is an absolute universal statement I
have the right to choose but of course
in an absolute and universal way nobody
has that right because that would mean
that you have the right to choose to do
literally anything you want to do you
have the right to make any choice at all
which of course you don't so when when
someone says women have the right to
choose what they really mean is they
mean it in an in a very limited sense
they mean specifically in their mind
that a woman has the right to choose to
end the life of her child before the
child emerges from the birth canal
so they put it forward as an absolute
unqualified statement but it actually is
a very qualified statement because they
are talking about one particular choice
that they believe a woman should be able
to make but if that choice to kill a
child is defensible and ethical it's not
defensible and ethical just because it's
a choice the fact that it's a choice is
irrelevant the question with abortion is
not whether a woman can choose but
whether an unborn human has a moral
claim to existence and personhood now if
he doesn't then a woman can choose
abortion if he does have that claim then
the choice of abortion belongs to the
same category as the choice of murder or
child molestation then that would be a
choice that yeah physically you can do
but you have no moral right to do it and
you shouldn't therefore have a legal
right to do it either now you'll notice
something you know gun rights activists
will will will talk about their right to
bear arms but they never talk about the
right to shoot right gun rights
activists aren't going to go around
saying I have the right to shoot
they have the right to bear arms but
their right to discharge those arms
depends quite significantly on why the
arms are being discharged and in what
context and at what target so no you
don't have the right to shoot
generally speaking you have the right
you have the right to bear the arms but
as far as shooting them that really is
very qualified it really depends on why
and where and in what direction you're
shooting and a choice is like that you
know your right to choose is contingent
not absolute
so to defend a choice on the basis that
it is a choice is very stupid all of
these arguments are very stupid but the
pro-abortion side of course doesn't have
any any other sort of argument at its
disposal unfortunately all right we'll
go to yeah we'll go to emails Matt wall
show at gmail.com Matt well show at
gmail.com this is from Isaac says hey
Matt you said something yesterday that
I'm not sure I agree with in that you
said that loving oneself is a byproduct
of loving others but doesn't scripture
say otherwise in that you need to love
others as much as you love yourself the
second greatest commandment there's a
saying that that's a bit of a spin off
of that commandment which is you grace
others as much as you grace yourself and
don't people who struggle with
self-hatred also struggle with loving
others as a result love your show and
you're down to earth and say it as it is
approach yeah well I think that there's
a misunderstanding Isaac about that
verse in scripture where it says love
others you know as you love yourself
Jesus there is not saying that you're
you know you're that self-love is the
foundational love and that you should
calibrate your love for other people
based on how much you happen to love
yourself that's not what Jesus is saying
what he's saying is I think just pretty
simple that you you know you look out
for your own interests and in a similar
way you should consider other people's
interests to be like your own you know
Thomas Aquinas says love to love is to
will the good of the other well you you
kind of naturally will the good for
yourself you want what is good for
yourself you may have some wrong ideas
about what's good but to the extent that
you understand what's good you want that
for yourself right
well what Jesus is saying is yeah do the
same for other people to want what is
best for others and try to help them
achieve what is best that's the point
and so you want what's best for yourself
really regardless of how you happen to
feel about yourself you may be feeling
kind of down about yourself you may be
struggling with your self-image or
whatever but you still wants what's best
for yourself unless you get to the point
of total self-loathing where you're at
the you know where you're you know at
the point of being almost suicidal well
now that's that of course would be
someone who doesn't want what's best for
themselves and that is bad I mean I'm
not advocating self-loathing obviously
we don't want to hate ourselves which we
shouldn't hate anyone including
ourselves ourselves but the point is we
can't hold other people hostage
according to our own emotions where
we're saying you know how I treat you is
going to depend entirely on how I happen
to be feeling and there are a lot of
people who operate that way in
relationships and it's deadly for a
relationship and that is not what Jesus
is saying and by the way keep in mind
that's the second greatest commandment
what was the first greatest first
greatest was love God so that's the
first thing the foundational love is not
the love for yourself or the love for
your neighbor the foundational love is
your love for God and through that love
you know that love becomes sort of the
fountain from which our love for
ourselves and try the people sort of
Springs so that's the way that I would I
would look at it but I I do still
believe that it
you're struggling with self-image if
you're feeling down about yourself
whatever the case may be I think the
best remedy for that is not to sit
around trying to conjure good feelings
about yourself the best remedy is to
focus on loving other people and loving
God just focus on loving outwardly
rather than inwardly and I think if you
do that
you're gonna find that you start to feel
better too
when you really focus on you know you
say I won't put this aside I'm just
going to go play with my kids spend some
time with my kids focus on loving them
being with them and I'm not gonna think
about myself and in the midst of doing
that of kind of losing yourself in in
that moment of being with with with
someone else that you love you may stop
for a second and realize oh wait a
second I'm actually feeling pretty good
about myself right now and the moment
that you realize that don't dwell on it
just say okay that's great put it to the
side focus back on other people I think
the more we focus on how we feel about
ourselves the worse we end up feeling
that's the point we end up kind of
caving in on ourselves because we're so
inwardly focused I think we should be
more outwardly focused and that was the
whole point I was trying to make there
this is from Jamie says hi Matt I love
your show agree with almost everything
you say I have a question though about
homosexuality CS Lewis says that he
can't judge gay people because he's
never struggled with that issue himself
it seems like a lot of Christians like
to condemn the sins that they've never
been tempted to commit meanwhile they
say nothing about the sins they do
struggle with what do you think about CS
Lewis's attitude I know you're a big fan
of his hi Jimmy yeah I am a big fan of
CS Louis and I'm familiar with the
passage you're referring to though it
doesn't say exactly that here's here's
what he says this is from surprised by
joy I believe he says I have said the
sin in question homosexuality is one of
the two gambling as the other which I
have never been tempted to commit I will
not indulge in futile philippics against
enemies I have never met in battle so
that's not the same thing as saying I
can't judge rather what he's saying is
he has no real insight into that
struggle because he's never experienced
it and it's rather easy for him to rail
against it because it is as he says
an enemy that he's never met in battle
so it's easy for him and I I think we
can and should still stand in opposition
to all sin including the ones that we've
never been tempted to commit ourselves
and I don't think CS Lewis would
disagree with that but I agree that
there is a tendency among Christians and
among all people to focus on the sins of
others that's what the whole you know
split splinter and your brother's eye
beam in your own eye he without sin
throw the first stone you know all of
that in the Gospels that's what all that
is about Jesus spends a lot of time on
this concept so here's how you look at
it every bad thing that you've ever done
and we've all done bad things right so
every bad thing you've ever done you've
done because two factors converged
desire and opportunity you did the bad
thing because you had the desire to do
it and you had the opportunity to do it
desire an opportunity we know what
desire means opportunity in this case
means not only the chance to do it
physically but the ability to do it in
our minds without consequence that's
what opportunity means so we've all told
lies right we've all told lies well why
did we tell those lies we told the lie
because we wanted to because we thought
that we would get something out of it
and because we encountered a situation
where we believed we could tell the lie
and get away with it and oftentimes we
find out in retrospect we were wrong
about that but but still we that's why
we did it so here's the point
you don't deserve credit for not doing
things which you've never had the desire
an opportunity to do in the first place
think about all the bad things you
haven't done think of the worst kinds of
murder
for instance okay why haven't you
murdered anyone assuming you haven't
well you might say oh I've never
murdered anyone because it's wrong but
is that really why you haven't done it
no you haven't done it because you never
wanted to you've never
once been seriously tempted to kill
someone and that's why you haven't done
it now it's true that it's wrong and
you're aware of that fact but you've
never been in a situation where the only
thing stopping you from killing someone
is that you know it's wrong the thing
that stops you from killing someone
every day in every moment of your life
is that you you just it's not in the
cards you said that you've never had
that temptation so the first sort of dam
that holds us back from committing a
particular sin is that we don't want to
commit that sin that's the number one
thing that stops us from doing most of
the bad things we don't do the second
dam not as strong as the first
especially if the first breaks is
opportunity so there may be a really bad
thing that we want to do but then so
that dam breaks but then we have that
second one holding there of what we
don't have the opportunity to do it the
problem though is is once the first dam
breaks and the only thing stopping you
is that you don't have the opportunity
to do it then eventually you'll find an
opportunity think about you know a guy
an unfaithful man in an unhappy marriage
who is a candidate for adultery like he
he would like to commit adultery he
would like to be with another woman
but he just has never found an
opportunity where he thinks he could do
it and get away with it well then that's
what's then in that case opportunity is
what's stopping him but most likely
eventually he'll find an opportunity for
himself because that's what people end
up doing and then what happens okay so
let's say you want to do the bad thing
you have the opportunity to do it now
what's the only thing that can stop you
now okay now this is where morality and
virtue come into play they didn't really
come into play before because it didn't
really matter because he didn't want to
do that thing anyway now the now the
last and final the failsafe is morality
and virtue and that's going to be the
only thing
that prevents you from doing that thing
because you want to do it you have the
opportunity now you now you need to call
a morality and virtue
I think CS Lewis's point is that if on
any particular sin you've never you know
faced those raging waters
you've never been under that waterfall
you've never felt the force of that
water or both of those dams break and
the only thing stopping you from
drowning in that sin is just your own
moral discipline CS Lewis decide is if
you've never been through that on any
particular issue then you have no right
to feel morally superior because it's
not your morals that prevented you from
doing it it's not your morals that saved
you from drowning your morals didn't
come into play what we need to do is
think what happens when I do have the
desire and opportunity to do a bad thing
even if we're even if they're just
little things I think for a lot of us if
we're honest we have to admit that
pretty much whenever we really want to
do something and we have the chance to
do it we do it whatever it is and and
these may be small things most of the
time I think a lot of us have maybe
never or almost never made a real moral
decision in our lives I think there are
a lot of us who have who have never
really committed a moral act not all of
us but I think for many of us every bad
thing we haven't done is because we just
so happened to never want to do to do
that thing and every good thing that
we've done it's because we happen to
want to do it we project the appearance
of living a moral life but really we're
only living according to our desires and
problem is it's only by accident then
that we aren't committing the most
heinous sins it's just an accident
of circumstance that we happen to not
want to do those things what happens
when we wake up one day and we find that
we really do want to do one of those
things we have gotten into the habit of
living according to our desire of living
according to desire and opportunity and
once once you go down that road you're
on the same Road as murderers and
rapists and everyone I mean you're you
may not be as far down the road as them
but you know those are people who are
living according to their desires and
their desires happen to be heinous
you're living according to your desires
to which are a little bit less heinous
but unless you learn to resist doing bad
things even when you have the desire and
opportunity to do them then you're just
going to drift down and end up over
there in that vicinity eventually unless
you die first I I think that's kind of
what CS Lewis's is is getting at and so
what should we do I think we have to get
accustomed to acting against our desires
and and against opportunity and that
means not committing the quote/unquote
little sins that's why the little sins
are so important because most of us are
only ever tempted to the quote-unquote
little sins and so you have to get
accustomed to resisting those
temptations and now on the other hand -
on the other hand - when it comes to
virtue it's sort of the inverse where we
have to get accustomed to doing good
things even when we really don't want to
do them and when we won't gain much from
doing them and when we when we we can't
do so without sacrifice at inconvenience
so kind of the subverting of desired
opportunity I think we need to get
ourselves accustomed to doing that and
that's part of what you know just is
just one example but that's part of what
fasting and those sorts of things are
about the point one of the points of
fasting is yeah I mean I I want to eat I
can eat in this case there's nothing
wrong with eating it's not it's not an
immoral thing but I'm kind of training
myself it's it's this is moral training
where I'm training myself to not do
something that I want to do and that's a
just a basic ability that we have to be
able to develop within ourselves and I
think a lot of us just do not have that
ability because we have never once
refrained from doing something we really
wanted to do alright so there's that and
we'll leave it there tomorrow just to
remind you we will be in Philadelphia
further for the pro-life rally against
bullying
11:44 locust streets if I remember the
address correctly 11:00 a.m. in
Philadelphia is gonna be a big group of
us there and it's gonna be a great event
so I hope it to see you there and if not
I'll talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed hey everybody its Andrew Clavin
host of the Andrew Clavin show so now
the Democrats are going to put on a show
it's the impeachment and constitutional
crisis show except without a real
impeachment or a real constitutional
crisis because they need a show to
replace the reality they've lost that's
on the Andrew Klavan show I'm Andrew
Clavin